وقع الرئيس بايدن يوم السبت على
اتفاق سقف الديون ليصبح قانونًا لتجنب حدوث
أول تقصير على الإطلاق ، جاء هذا التوقيع
في أعقاب خطاب الرئيس بايدن
من المكتب البيضاوي يوم الجمعة ،
وكان الإعداد نفسه مهمًا لأنه
أكد على اللحظة لهذا
البيت الأبيض الذي كان لآخر مرة.  عدة أسابيع
كانت تعمل تحت تهديد التخلف عن
السداد المحتمل بعد أيام قليلة ، والذي
يمكن أن يكون له عواقب اقتصادية كارثية
أشار إليها الرئيس بايدن نفسه في خطابه
وأكد حقًا على
الشراكة بين الحزبين خلال الأسابيع العديدة الماضية
بالطبع كانت هذه الصفقة
نتيجة مفاوضات مضنية
بين مفاوضي البيت الأبيض
والمفاوضين الجمهوريين ،
وأقر الرئيس بايدن بأن هناك
تنازلات من كلا الجانبين وأن
الجميع لم يحصلوا على ما يريدونه ، لكنه
أشاد برئيس مجلس النواب مكارثي في
تلك التصريحات قائلاً إنه
شارك في مفاوضات حسنة النية لكن
الرئيس بايدن أخذ أيضًا
الفرصة للتأكيد على الشراكة بين الحزبين
والوحدة الآن بالطبع مع هذه الصفقة التي تم
توقيعها لتصبح قانونًا الآن تعلق
حد الديون حتى أوائل عام 2025 مما يزيل خطر
التخلف عن السداد بعيدًا عن الطاولة بعد أيام فقط
من الوقت الذي كانت فيه وزارة الخزانة الأمريكية
تتخلف عن السداد
بريسيلا ألفاريز سي إن إن البيت الأبيض